today I report on a Britain that is
growing creating jobs and paying its way
we took difficult decisions in the teeth
of opposition and it worked
Britain is walking tall again we believe
people should be working for themselves
not working for the taxman tax really
doesn't have to be taxing and this
spells the death of the annual tax
return Scotch whisky and other spirits
will be cut by two percent cider duty by
two percent wine duty will be frozen
more pub saved jobs created family
supported and a penny off a pint for the
third year in a row poverty is down
frozen again it saves the family around
ten pounds every time they fill up their
car that's ten pounds off a tank with
the Tories and every fiscal event under
this government I said we would all be
in this together and here is the grill
the original debt target I set out in my
first budget has been met we will end
this Parliament with Britain's national
debt share falling the Sun is starting
to shine and we are fixing the real